hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from this year's singfield Cup
this is round four and it is Wesley so
versus rard rort it's a game that could
have very very uh great importance on
the uh standings of the world top 20 and
also on who gets to play in the next Fay
candidates tournament that will be held
in 2024 uh but before we check out the
game and before we check out the you
know what what's happening with the
ratings and who is currently in the
candidates tournament and everything um
uh you know around that topic I would
just like to mention that yesterday I
received an email uh with uh one of the
subscribers claiming that he is
unsubscribing from the channel after
some five five years uh because I've
started producing paid content now what
he meant by this is that he went to my
channel and uh he uh checked out what
videos were available on the channel and
he clicked on one video and the video
said that it's only available to paid
members now this is not because I create
videos for paid members is because um I
I do allow paid membership on the this
channel but as I've said when I've
allowed it uh you will not be getting
any special content for that and uh you
will still be getting everything for
free as as does anyone else it's merely
a means of supporting the channel if
anyone wishes to do so now what I've
done is that now YouTube has a feature
that when I make a video sometimes I
make a video and I schedule it okay I
schedule it for maybe it will be
published in two hours or maybe in three
hours maybe I want to publish a video
let's say at 2: p.m. 1 at 2: p.m. and if
I'm making two videos I'm going to
publish one at maybe 2: p.m. one at 600
p.m. or 800 p.m. a.m. uh when I do this
sometimes uh uh okay let's say it's 9:00
a.m. 9:00 a.m. in the morning and I said
okay the video will be uh viewable by
everyone at 2 p.m uh you know some 5
hours from now uh paid members of the
channel are able to watch the video
immediately and that's basically the
only perk they are getting but uh it's
not uh hidden content it's not uh paid
content everyone is still getting the
same amount of content for free only uh
paid members of the channel get to see
it maybe maybe sometimes an hour sooner
sometimes two hours sooner sometimes
maybe even five hours sooner I have no
idea when I when I make the videos it
you know it differs from day to day uh
but just wanted to clear that up if if
you see that you know something is maybe
hidden behind the pay wall it's not
really it's it's going to be available
like maybe in half an hour or an hour or
or two hours or you know whatever
whatever time of the day uh just wanted
to clear that up uh in case some of you
also uh you know happen to think that uh
so now that have cleared it up let's
check out the game so Wesley has the
white pieces and he opens with Pawn to
C4 he goes for the English against
Rapport and rort goes for Knight to F6
we have Knight to C3 G6 and pawn to E4
we have Pawn to D6 and pawn to D4 so the
English opening but now Bishop to G7 and
F3 transposing into the king's Indian
defense um uh with with Pawn to F3 can't
remember the name of that line I know it
like uh it's the um uh let me just
check uh yeah the samish variation it's
been a while since I've seen it couldn't
remember the the name yeah the samish
variation we have castles uh and now
Knight G to E2 we have Knight to C6 and
okay uh there are a lot of games in this
exact same setup uh Pawn to C5 or Pawn
to E5 are the uh more common moves here
even A6 but Knight to C6 is still very
strong we have Bishop to E3 we have A6
and now Queen to D2 at some point of
course we'll try to contest against the
dark Square Bishop of blacks and now uh
a rook to B8 is what's usually played
here we have Bishop to D7 and now Rook
to B1 preparing to advance the pawn all
the way to B4 Pawn to H5 by reard and
now Pawn to B4 by Wesley and now there
are some games where Pawn to E6 was
played but here we have Knight to H7 by
Rapport and it is now as of move 10 that
we have a completely new game uh so okay
Wesley grabs more space in the center he
plays Pawn to D5 it's a it's a trade-off
really because he gives up the E5 square
that reard will be able to use but he
does get the D4 Square for his Knight so
you have to give something to get
something Knight to E5 we have Knight to
D4 and Rook to C8 now we have Bishop to
E2 preparing the castle and now Pawn to
C5 striking in the center D captures and
C6 alasa you could also capture with the
B Pawn but then Rook captures and maybe
you move the queen maybe you double up
on the seep file or maybe even triple up
so not something maybe that you want to
allow so the capture on C6 and now
Bishop captures on C6 we have Rook to C1
B5 is also possible but of course black
will not capture black will just move
the bishop and now you kind of have to
worry about your weird pawns being
placed this way so after Bishop captures
in C6 Rook to C1 and now Bishop back to
D7 we have Knight to D1 Shifting the
Knight to B2 to help out with the
defense of the C4 pawn and pawn to B5
Now by reard Knight to B2 and this is
where the magic starts happening Knight
captures on C4 four Knight captures on
C4 Pawn to E5 now attacking the Knight
Knight to B3 and now B captures on C4 we
have Bishop captures on C4 and raport
now sacrifices The Exchange uh with Rook
captures on C4 now if this was uh anyone
other than Rapport you know from the
world top 20 they would go Bishop to B5
save their A6 pawn and now everything
gets traded off let's say captures
captures captures you're going to play
captures here your B Pawn controls the a
pawn so you don't have to worry about it
for the moment and the game continues
but rort always plays magical chess and
here we have Rook captures on C4 uh Rook
captures and now Bishop to B5 and I
always mention this when Wesley always
playing uh yes Rapport is an incredible
player he you know he he always um also
tries to emulate tal he he he loves
sacrificing he loves um wild positions
but wly so is a fish random World chess
champion and maybe against him you you
want to uh you know you want to play a
bit more bit more calmly uh but you know
if you're if you if you leave live
Dangerously in in in your heart then of
course it's very very difficult um uh to
play calm moves but okay Rook to C1 we
have Pawn to D5 now as uh okay the D6
Pawn is very weak here and here his idea
is that if Wesley plays e captures on D5
he can play E4 even and now if F
captures Queen to H4 with check will
make it very very problem atic for white
to defend with the bishop here the
bishop here the queen attacking The Rook
it's a really nice position for black H
but Whitley says nope I'm going to
capture with the queen queen captures on
D5 and now still Queen to H4 with check
G3 and queen to F6 now putting pressure
on the F3 Pawn King to F2 and now Rook
to d8 attacking the White Queen and now
planning Rook to D3 to put pressure on
the bishop and also paralyze the bishop
as the F3 Pawn will be in a lot of
danger here and with Wesley has two
options here he could put the Rook to C5
or he could the queen to C5 or he could
put the queen to B7 C5 not the best as
you allow the dark squore Bishop into
the game with Tempo so Queen to B7 was
played and now Rober plays Rook to D3
and here Wesley has to be very careful
what is rapper's idea well we already
said let's say plays Rook H to D1 it's
your only piece not doing anything the
idea is Knight to G5 that's the the idea
so the Knight was um completely out of
the game here here it's very active
putting pressure on the F3 pawn and if
you capture then rook and queen are
going to go after that F3 Pawn so you
don't really have a um a good way of um
playing for any advantage here with
white you have to sell for a draw here
with Queen to C8 check and after Bishop
to f8 you have to capture on D3 that's
all you have you have to allow Queen
captures an F3 check King G1 now Bishop
will capture on D3 and now you have to
go for Bishop captures on G5 Bishop
captures on e4 threat Checkmate and now
Queen to H3 defending but this will now
uh end up in a in a nice Perpetual where
it will of course end in a draw uh but
after Rook to D3 uh Queen to B6 was
played Wesley sees right through that
and now he puts pressure on the black
queen and also defends his Bishop on E3
and what can rer do if he moves the
queen let's say to E7 then we have Rook
H to D1 the move that wasn't possible a
mov go now very much is Rook captures on
D1 Rook captures and let's say queen
captures on B4
and okay equal equal pawns but
um and the white king might be a little
bit weak but not too much and The Rook
will of course Prevail against the uh
the Lesser piece so after Queen to B6
raer says all right we're going to trade
Queen captures we have Bishop captures
and now Knight to G5 again getting the
Knight into the game with Tempo and now
even Pawn to H4 by Wesley allowing the
capture on F3 and what do you capture
with well doesn't really matter Wesley
cap Raper capture with the Knight but if
he captures with the Rook but if he
captures with the Knight then we play
Rook H to D1 and after a trade here
let's say captures captures where is the
Knight going that's the question the D4
Square guarded three times so you're not
going there uh you can only go to H2
with the idea of Shifting the Knight
over to G4 but now let's say Knight to
C5 A4 is coming and it's just uh it's
always going to be uh White up the
exchange and white white will win this
game so after Pawn to H4 rer play Rook
captures an F3 this comes with check and
now after King to G2 and now it looks a
bit weird because your knight is hanging
and if you move the Knight your Rook is
hanging so what was rapper's idea here
uh well he sacrifices the second
exchange he plays Rook captures on B3
you know in for a penny in for a pound a
captures on B3 and now Knight captures
on e4 so what's his compensation here
well he does have one Pawn for the uh
for the two sacrificed exchanges and he
does have the bishop pair as you know
the bishop pair could be incredibly
strong uh but Wesley plays Rook H to E1
attacks the Knight you have to move it
Knight to D2 and now Rook to C8 with
check here the position repeated a few
times Rook to C7 King to G8 Rook to C8
check King to H7 and now Rook to C7 King
to G8 but now of course rapper did not
Wesley did not repeat he does not want
to draw this game he played Rook to E3
he defended his B3 pawn and he was in
this position on move 37 that rard rort
um resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh the problem is
the Knight is trapped there's no way to
save the Knight to give you an example
let's say play something with black as
there really isn't all that much to play
let's say get get the king into the game
or Rook to C2 uh the Knight can only
move back you're going to play a knight
to B1 you're going to attack the Knight
once again with Rook E1 the Knight has
to go to A3 attack The Rook but now you
move the Rook with check and after the
king moves you play Rook to A1 you've
trapped the Knight and now you just
capture it that's pretty much that
that's all there is to the position
position so that's why of course after
Rook e 3 rer resigned and a very nice
victory for Wesley so and what I wanted
to show you uh is this this this is the
uh the rating list the live rating list
as of yesterday even though this is a
game from round four yesterday round
five was played but one other important
game happened and that is ala fucha
versus Leon arunan where arunan defeated
ala and you can see uh out of out of 22
people here alza has dropped the most
points ala and the Rapport as you can
see here that the Rapport and Wesley are
almost equally rated Rapport being down
only one point one point that was at the
beginning of this month of November uh
but he's now down 21 uh points and ala
is down 21.3 points as there are two
more spots there are available uh for
the FED candidates tournament one will
be uh decided with the with the uh newly
created Fay circuit and one will be
decided via highest rating as of January
2024 so top is Magnus Carlson he's not
going to be playing in the candidates as
far as we know then Fabby he's already
qualified Hikaru he just
qualified via the F Grand Prix then ding
of course he is the champion Yanni
ponesi he is qualified already as he's
the former uh Challenger and now we have
Wesley so who has overtook ala fua as
the highest rated player and if he can
uh keep this until January 2024 when it
will be decided he will get that spot in
the next a candidates Tournament of
course it's very close it's 2756
2755 uh but you never know but others
have a chance as well Anish 2753 and
it's going to be a great fight via the
FED secret as well as I think U well let
me just check I don't want to trick you
guys or anything uh let me just check
who is currently leading yeah uh sorry
about that yeah Fab is leading but he is
already qualified and then you have
Anish giri with 84 points in the f f
circuit Gish with 79 and Wesley so also
with 78 so Wesley has a great chance of
qualifying either the the FIA circuit or
either the via the top top rating from
January 2024 so we'll see how it goes
for him as the tournament is still being
played both him and alira are playing in
this tournament and it's only been five
rounds so we'll see quite a lot
depending on this not just the uh the
you know uh who who who wins the the
singfield cup uh so yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it uh another
classical game where Wesley just plays
Immaculate chess and raer who plays raer
chess he sacrificed not one but two
exchanges and in the end you know it
didn't really do all that much but it
was a really tough position a poisonous
one and you know one one simple misstep
from Wesley and it could have gone uh in
uh completely the other way around uh so
yeah once again really hope you guys
enjoyed it hopefully I've also cleared
that up regarding the the paid content
on the channel there is none it's merely
you know for for the supporters of the
channel maybe get to see a video like
this one I'm that I'm uploading maybe
maybe the sporters will see it like half
an hour or an hour before everyone else
gets to see it so it's not it's not a
big deal but sort of a small thank you
but yeah I would like to thank David
gasparian desert send software more ding
games thank you GG and Mr Never
Surrender for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day